[Música]
yo sé situado a lo largo de las costas
normandas es un paraíso tan desconocido
como pintoresco un archipiélago que
alberga un entorno de naturaleza todavía
salvaje solamente la isla grande está
habitada una franja de tierra de un
kilómetro y medio de largo y 500 metros
de ancho
cada día las 62 casas de la isla reciben
la visita de eric fromm o el guardián
del archipiélago
de hecho aquí en la isla de hecho si no
estamos conectados a ninguna red del
continente ni de teléfono ni
electricidad ni de agua
así que el agua potable llega a todos
los días por barco luego el ix se
encarga de distribuirla entre los
habitantes el empleado municipal solo
dispone de esta cisterna para toda la
isla entonces hay que evitar el
desperdicio bueno no hay que bañarse
todos los días o tomar duchas cortas y
de hecho tres cuartas partes de las
personas cuando lavan platos los meten
en un pequeño balde 5 litros de agua y
tratan de tener mucho cuidado
este estilo de vida por fuera del tiempo
lejos de los estándares de la comodidad
de la vida moderna hace parte del
encanto de la vida insular para los
mayores ellos conocieron a los de antes
y hablan continuamente sobre su historia
es difícil basta con que le pregunte al
otro jorobado cómo es el invierno que
llevamos en invierno pero si no hay nada
más no hay nadie yo sé es sólo nuestra
misma isla no no es para nada la misma
isla que en verano durante el verano
tratamos de hacer que las personas
sonrían a pesar de la magia del lugar la
isla se ha despoblado muchos han ido
conocidos antes nos quedábamos 60
durante el invierno ahora ya no hay
nadie cuántos son en invierno 23
personas dos marineros eso es todo
porque había una granja había una
escuela donde yo estudiaba había un
párroco había dos hoteles que estaban
abiertos había guardianes en el faro
ahora ya no hay nada
el mar siempre está presente en su sed
por todas partes - en este pequeño valle
conocido como la granja aquí en el suelo
fértil incluso hay un rebaño de vacas no
más granjas no más escuelas desde el
regreso a las clases en 1971 la iglesia
que colinda con la escuela
[Música]
yo sé también tenía más pescadores y
muchos más hombres fuertes que
trabajaban en las canteras de granito el
faro tenía un guardián pero ese ya no es
el caso desde hace una decena de años
[Música]
ahora la isla vive del turismo incluso
cuando no parece querer despertarse
el transbordador sigue recibiendo
visitantes de un día algunos descubren
la isla otros regresan una y otra vez
como este pintor
cuando desembarcó me doy un baño de
verdor me gusta mucho desde su
jubilación bernard ver no se viene aquí
todas las semanas para dibujar conoce
este archipiélago de memoria
no tengo en cuenta el bien yo hoy no
haya es impecable entonces es posible ir
casi a todas partes
pronto habrá zona sé que va a salir por
allá entonces trato de no tenerlo de
frente cuando me siento trabajar después
de unas cuantas horas la naturaleza
salvaje de la isla invade poco a poco el
lienzo del pintor con más flores recto y
va a estar florido
si bien la belleza de los paisajes de
xosé es una fuente inagotable de
inspiración para los artistas los
visitantes también vienen a admirar las
mayores mareas de europa aquí el nivel
del mar puede bajar hasta 14 metros
en el lapso de unas cuantas horas el
archipiélago pasa entonces de tener unas
50 islas a más de 360 yo sé se vuelve
entonces el archipiélago más importante
de europa se oyen los pájaros se oyen de
vez en cuando los motores ven cómo es de
pesado el ambiente el corro jo patas
rojas y el cuerpo blanco y negro pronto
los veremos si se quieren dejar ver
cuando este mundo submarino queda al
descubierto
olivia rivero un único guía del
archipiélago hace que los turistas no
aprovechen
una vez que ubique que es algo señal
que coca o la coqueta y el paludismo
como yo
olivia recorre este archipiélago desde
hace más de 10 años y todavía se sigue
sorprendiendo
es una admiración constante estoy en los
mismos lugares y me siguen sorprendiendo
a nuevas cosas hasta ahora este pequeño
rincón de paraíso ha conservado su
carácter salvaje en verano hasta 3.000
visitantes diarios vienen a jose para
preservar este frágil lugar la alcaldía
está pensando en limitar las visitas
turísticas
[Música]
sí